thank you and this is a joint work with
mark young and omri when I was just in
Princeton last year so let me start with
a confession should apologize this talk
is not really about a low point amount
of time most of the of the talks we've
seen the workshop is stuff like a NZ vs
fast or like N squared wrists and cubed
and most of them needed to assume a safe
except the last talk and the reduction
size from strong eth was a 2 to the n
over 3 here we act we are going to
distinguish polynomial versus quasi
point on our algorithm so slightly
coarser but still pretty fine grained
and we use ETH to assume that's at
requires to the Omega n time and the
reduction sites the weed is a 2 through
10 ok so what I mean by a dentist k sub
graph with perfect completeness so you
all know the cake cake clique problem I
give you a graph and you want to find
I'm asking it does it contain a click
sighs k and carb just walked in and
decades ago he proved that it's a an
np-hard thanks so if the problem is
np-hard suicide problem is NP also want
to relax it won't define approximations
and the one thing that has been studied
a lot in complexity theory is relaxing k
so we compared the the completeness will
be actually the cliq will help sighs k
and the Sun this one's something much
much smaller than K so almost the entire
gap like n to the 1 minus epsilon and
even this huge gap is np-hard after a
lot of awesome work in complexity theory
but I think for a lot of applications a
more natural relaxation is to relax
click so we again we look both sub
graphs will be of size K but instead of
requiring the sub do we actually have a
click we just want something with the
high density so 1 minus Delta for some
constant Delta and so far they've been a
horizontal zero nothing was known about
there's no harness results but there are
algorithms there are a few algorithm
surrounding in Kwazii polynomial time
and this second one is actually sort of
related is sort of a sketching and
solved similar to the last last thought
we sent you saw yeah but so there was no
harness and somewhat disturbing
what happens if we relax both so again I
dense I only require density 99% of
something and I also let you look at a
much smaller sub graph and probably no
surprise by now but our main result is
that this is a ETA chart so swimming
exponential time about this big stakes
quasi point on our time matching the
upper bounds for the harder problem this
earlier so I I said that there is the
absolutely nothing nothing known so
there is some there are some harness
results for dentist k sub graph but in
the sparse versus very sparse regime so
we're not comparing click in almost like
we're camping even the completeness is a
sub constant density so very small
density in both cases and probably the
closest in spirit to our theorem is a
great paper by a swash code and the the
hardest assumption is incomparable but
very similar so we assume there is no n
so our reduction is a it's a
deterministic reduction but it takes
through 10 he's a randomized reduction
and takes to the end to the epsilon so
very similar let me just point out the
besides the fact that we get perfect
completeness our reduction is also way
simpler so I'll show it to next should L
show you the entire reduction one slide
this is a beautiful production when it's
like 60 pages so and there are other
assumptions all of them are sort of
different assumptions not non of a we
don't have MP harness and in this regime
we don't have we don't have a cozy
polynomial time algorithm we should get
empty awareness hopefully or in
algorithms even better okay so the
domain technique in the construction is
the birth repetition
and this is not my idea this idea is
there's been around for the last couple
of years and the term repetition was
coined by Russell and Scott and Donna
and their CC paper a couple of years ago
and they proved the something quantum
you can ask Russell later I don't know
it is there is a they also there also
proved a quasi polynomial time harness
for dense constraint satisfaction
problems and for those free game so
let's keep those reefs years have been a
couple of a few applications of this
paradigm for harness a quasi polynomial
time harness in applications in game
theory and this talk will tell you about
densest k sub graph and hopefully the
next paper is by you and so I'm asking
for EM asking you to prove Kwazii ponen
a time alga quasi ponen on a time lower
bounds I don't know for what but I think
a great candidate is this so this is a
controversial slide of the talk before I
go on to tell you what is birthday
repetition let me just mention that all
these problems have quasi polynomial
time algorithm so matching upper bounds
okay so let me show you the reduction
one slide it's a nice example of like
how to apply birth repetition so you can
be this the next next paper so we start
from a a to CSP thing for example 3
coloring that has some gap and so
deciding if we can satisfy all the
constraints or 1 minus epsilon of the
constraints the requires exponential
time so we assume and now we want to
construct a graph so this let me just
mention this is not the graph this is a
CSP were constructing a new graph in
which we're going to try to solve
dancers k sub graph so our vertex set is
the assignments two subsets of root n
variables so it takes some subset of our
route and variables and we look at the
air for every any any vector of
assignments for this route in top o we
have a verdict swear every route and
every choice of fruit on top on every
choice of assignment to the student opal
and so here you see that the size of the
reduction is approximately to the root n
ETH assume that we need to the end time
to solve it so the time the running time
in terms of capital and is the end to
the log in which is what we expect
so our edges are the simplest choice of
edges that you can pick simply if if I
you have two routes and topples of
assignment first of all you want it to
be consistent so if the two vertices is
given assignment to the same variable it
should be the same assignment and if
they give assignment to two variables
that we have a constraint then this is a
CSP constraint we want them to satisfy
the constraint and the completely so we
here we have a click just pick a
satisfying assignment and there are n
choose root n tuples the correspond to
the sermon it's going to be okay and so
this is the entire reduction just one
slight surprise promised let me show you
so I have to prove an hour Sunday
soundness I want to prove that if the
CSP doesn't have a good assignment then
I want to prove the graph doesn't have a
large dense sub graph
so here we get to use the birthday
paradox and the idea is that if every
this birth repetition if every vertex
has root in as root n variables then if
I if I look at the intersection of two
root n tuples I expect to see a concert
number of constraints tested in this
intersection and so the intuition is you
know if the Tuesday speaking if it's a
no instance of you can satisfy it most 1
minus epsilon after our constraints then
I expect to have some constant fraction
of the edges that will catch those
violations of the ok so we're almost
done you'd hope but no so unfortunately
now so it's a turn out to be much much
much trickier than that so in most
applications in all other applications
of the birthday repetition the
repetition part is very simple so I I
didn't define Q birth repetition with
Alice and Bob but you can think of a
metaphorically as a like a a to pervert
game and then the queries are
independent so the the query the choice
because it because I'm looking all the
all the constraints I'm taking all the
vertices all them take all pairs of
races so typically it's very it's very
easy to prove that the repetition part
works we're dense sk somewhere if we
have a palm so the problem is that this
dentist k sub graph is a very simple
problem so it's hard in force structure
it's hard to force the the Killik a sub
graph to actually correspond to an
assignment
and essentially the only thing that we
know is that the graph is dense and its
large but you know that's it's very very
little structure and we have this
metaphor it's like proving a parallel
petition theorem but which are
notoriously hard but here we have this
additional obstacle the now Allison Bob
might even give multiple answers to the
same variable and it just ignores some
other variables and the sort of notice
that we don't we we only get harness in
the kia you can show that it's hard to
distinguish the case we click and
density 1 minus delta and if this is
like a nice nice barrier repletion there
is no reason why we can't amplify this
error and get a then C 1 verse dance
density Delta and we I don't know how to
do is that be very excited to find out
okay so so what can we still do so again
what we know is that the graph the sub
graph is large and it's dense and that's
the only thing that we can use so let me
show you a one slide samuray a summary
of analysis is not not as simple as a
reduction so we're going to do this
entropy counting argument which think of
this game I'm i have this supposed by
contradiction that I have a large click
in the graph and i'm going to pick a
vertex random so remember our vertices
are assignments to root and topple of
variables so i have to choose the
variables and I have to choose
assignments and because the the sub
graph is large it means that I am taking
a random uniformly random vertex from
the from the sub graph that means I have
a large a lot of entropy in this process
i'm picking a random vertex from a large
so i'm gonna have a lot of entropy so at
least one of those who'd have a lot of
entropy either a choice of variables or
the choice of assignments so if the
choice of variables has almost maximum
entropy then we can show that the
subgraph almost corresponds to an actual
assignment to the CSP and if it's an
actual assignment to the CSP then by
this birthday paradox we actually get a
the sub graph is the audience
if we have a lot of entropy in the
choice of assignments it means you are
giving different assignments to the same
variable and then again you have have
many violations of the consistency
constraints so either way with one of
those you get a lot of violations and
you get low density
so i have no idea i'm doing in time I'm
sure I'm Way too fast for a but I have
one more slide with open prongs and then
you can take take a breather so here
here's a warm-up open problem I think we
should be very easy but again I don't
know how to do this so prove the same
result that we had but for a by sub
graph dentist k x sub graph so we have a
bipartite graph and you want to find a
cave areas with the most edges like a
cake lick versus a k by click versus Y
minus Delta sparse and like I mentioned
I you know this technique should give a
click versus density Delta it'll be
great and one more thing is in the
sparse verse is a very sparse regime we
so here we have to use ETH reserves
Kwazii polynomial time algorithm but in
sparse versus very sparse regime there
should be an I don't know no no we don't
have any good excuse not to have any
harness and 11 upon the being kaylene
ask me after getting stuck last time is
about the fixed parameter tractability
of this problem I don't think anything
is now
that's it thank you look at the fellow
disciple questions so have question yeah
just some of the technical issues that
you're going to seem very similar to
direct product testing have you looked
at direct product testing I don't think
I have so what's that would be a good
direct product testing you're giving up
time God give it access to an Oracle
that's supposed to be evaluating some
function k tuples are on sets of
elements and then you want to check
whether there really is a function
that's being applied because only the
Oracle gives you some key to pull values
and you want to find say all the
functions that approximately agree with
many many outputs of the Oracle so it's
the same kind of issue of picking tuples
that intersect in checking consistency
on those people on the intersection yeah
I so I think I think I see where you're
going I suspect that uh in in those
cases you're sort of designing the
algorithm that would check the well that
will test if it's actually a direct
product or not and here's sort of i'm
here I you know I want just if I'm
actually given a real assignment or not
but I'm only love to use the how many
edges I have you know that's how many
edges you have will be how well the
algorithm
the test there's certain canonical test
that i think are covered by your edges
okay I'm let's like take it offline
button eat other questions all right so
that's like okay